hi my name is Sarah and I've been priced
out of the housing market in fact I'm
one of the majority of my generation who
can't afford a home and in 2017 home
ownership amongst young Australians has
fallen to the lowest level in recorded
history so foolishly or otherwise I
decided to build my own home but the
prognosis wasn't good there either
architects cater for the 1% builders are
scarce so service is inconsistent and
prices are high the single biggest
investment in my life and I was amazed
how little self-determination choice and
ultimately control I had what's more I
was doubly surprised at how vulnerable
this made me feel frankly I felt trapped
so I reflected on this for quite some
time and I realized what I wanted was
democratized design and construction and
that led to me asking one very simple
question what is building a house what
is it well it turns out that building a
house is making a series of decisions
some with physical consequences within a
defined set of parameters now having
worked in software applications for some
time now this all sounded very familiar
to me
I also couldn't understand why we build
on site no other major assembly in our
lives is constructed like this your car
doesn't come to you in pieces with an
extra 10% just in case to be assembled
at the mercy of the elements so why
should your house so I built a computer
game a game that allows you to design
your home and have it delivered to you a
game that puts the home builder back at
the center of the largest purchase in
their life elevating them from spectator
to player a game with full visibility of
the costs and environmental impact of
each new attribute you add using modular
components players select items from
their library and drag them into their
world each item be at a wall a solar
battery or even an armchair contains all
of the information for the system to
calculate costs environmental impact and
even a happiness tally for the player
83% of home builders said that next to
cost environmentally friendly features
were the most important things to them
so out of the gate homes are integrated
with solar systems born green
sustainable housing is often associated
with wealth and affluence but that
shouldn't be the case in fact truly
sustainable housing should be available
to everyone and affordable for all so I
had found a way to get the control back
that I was craving and give it to others
but something was still bugging me
something was still keeping me up at
night what about those people who who
have genuinely no control over where
they live every hour in the space of
your intermission 4,000 new homes are
needed in the world wrap your head
around that number that's an astonishing
35 million homes globally every year and
in Australia alone we have a shortfall
of 250,000 dwellings and in addition in
addition to that we have 190,000
families on the assisted housing
waitlist families in need of a home
between now and 2050 when the global
population is set to move from today's
7.6 billion into tomorrow's nine point
eight billion people hundreds of
millions of people will experience
security health and safety issues
imagine if you can not feeling secure in
your home not from crime not from theft
but from the fact that the building
you're in the building you're in might
not be structurally sound or built from
non-toxic components or meet local
natural disaster standards it's the 21st
century and this just isn't good enough
what if what if we could restore control
and dignity to those individuals by
giving them a home but not just any home
the their home and a home of their
design we're currently adapting our game
so that when a player builds a home
they're contributing to a home for
someone in need and I know this sounds
like a lofty goal
is ridiculously ambitious but today our
current operating model operates at a
ten to one ratio so for every ten homes
we build we can build a home for someone
in need this is made possible because
today with design for manufacturing
assembly which uses light gauge steel
frame construction shipped and assembled
on-site we can decrease construction
costs by 20% an environmental waste by
15% saving time money and keeping tons
of waste out of landfills the power in
modular construction is that you can
build year-round with confidence in your
costs in your quality and in your
delivery date in your build date no
wouldn't it be crazy we're gonna be
great
but that doesn't get me to my goal my
goal is one for one so I've been
traveling the world looking at different
alternatives of construction 3d printing
trying to find technology that will help
me deliver on my ambition 3d printing is
so exciting and so promising offering a
40% reduction in cost and near zero
waste and this is just to name a few but
some of the really exciting innovations
happening all over the world are
happening in Italy France to buy in
Australia and they use robotic arms to
print everything from solid stone to
concrete to wax in Italy they have
developed a technique using sorrell
cement sorrell cement was originally
invented in 1867 and it's the beautiful
chemical marriage of magnesium oxide and
local sand which they can now use to
print solid stone walls and in France
they have a regulator approved although
still experimental process whether
prynt two parallel tracks of foam
insulation and pour concrete in the
middle to create solid stone and in
Dubai sitting at the foot of those two
glorious Emirates Towers is a vision of
the future in the middle of the desert
they've got their experimental office of
the future which is constructed using 3d
printed concrete which was printed in
China and shipped and assembled on
location in Dubai and not to be outdone
in Australia we've pioneered an amazing
technology that allows you to print wax
molds and pour concrete over the top of
them allowing you to create really
intricately beautiful and cost-effective
facades
that you can see in person the next time
you travel the London Underground but
all of these things are tools hammer of
tomorrow if you like and the one common
thread that connects all these things is
computer-aided design we will need
models to build using these techniques
models like the ones being developed by
players in our game I want to put every
person that wants one in a home of their
own design and there are many more
applications still we could usher in an
entirely new empowered experience of
special needs or aged care accommodation
and we could provide rapid on-site
assistance in emergency housing
situations in the words of one of my
players I want to take matters into my
own hands and live by example thank you
you